leur côté les russes aussi poursuivre
leur offensive diplomatique après la
chine sergueï lavrov est en inde ce
jeudi new delhi est un grand
consommateur de gaz russe l'inde s'est
abstenue lors du vote au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu sur la résolution qui
condamne et la russie et sa guerre
bonjour bruno daroux bonjour j'ai eu
l'idée c'est de resserrer les liens
entre les russes et les indiens oui
alors l'idée plus globale de sergueï
lavrov s'est effectué une tournée dans
les pays qui ne sont pas identifiés
clairement comme étant dans le camp
occidental il y a eu évidemment la chine
à hyères qui est le principal allié de
la russie pour l'instant mais évidemment
l'étape indienne est quand même très
importantes d'abord parce que c'est
c'est un pays lui aussi qui compte
beaucoup sur la scène mondiale de par sa
taille de par sa population
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait eu le vote à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu très très
défavorable à la russie en fait les
russes eux compter le le poids de chaque
pays et combien de population et cetera
dont vous additionnez la chine et l'inde
déjà vous êtes à presque la moyens ou
carrément à la moitié de l'humanité donc
cette étape est importante
il faut dire que la la russie et l'inde
ont des liens effectivement économique
et même diplomatique très important
l'armement militaire de l'inde est
assurée à presque 80 % par la russie les
liens économiques globaux sont très
importants près de la moitié des
importations indiennes proviennent de
russie donc c'est pourquoi la ne peut
pas faire n'importe quoi dans cette
crise et puis elle à la concurrence de
la chine elle ne veut pas laisser la
chine seule alors en tête à tête avec la
russie d'où le fait qu'elle s'est
abstenu lors du vote à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu et sergueï lavrov
aujourd'hui bien il compte bien pousser
son avantage ce qui est d'ailleurs un
peu beaucoup les occidentaux le
président américain il ya quelques jours
joe biden a qualifié l'attitude indienne
comme étant un peu hésitante et a
rappelé que c'était pourtant une
démocratie on la surnomme même la plus
grande démocratie du monde et la
secrétaire la ministre britannique des
affaires étrangères li strauss et en ce
moment aussi à new delhi elle elle va
quitter new delhi juste avant l'arrivée
de sergueï lavrov pour mettre aussi un
coup de pression sur l'inde vont lui
dire rappelez vous au lien rappelez vous
que vous êtes dans le camp des
démocraties et que vous devez donc
affirmer davantage votre choix mais
évidemment il y aura aussi le son de
cloche de sergueï lavrov et l'inde va
certainement continuer à maintenir cette
position un peu équilibristes on voit
bien que la guerre redessine la
géopolitique elle dévoile aussi les
coulisses du pouvoir ou au kremlin
d'après les services de renseignement
américain et britannique poutine bruno
est mal informé sur le conflit en fait
il serait entouré de conseillers qui
n'oseraient pas lui dire la vérité ça
expliquerait ce qu'il se passe sur le
terrain en ukraine oui alors les
services de sécurité militaire et les
services de sécurité par des
britanniques et américains visiblement
se sont assez bien renseigné on va y
revenir et en fait ce qui se passerait
en russie selon eux c'est
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit c'est
le dernier étage avant poutine les
conseillers proches qu'ils n'oseraient
pas vu la nature du régime vue que s'ils
ont contredit le patron est bien et peut
il peut vous en cuir donc et n'oseraient
pas remonter les infos qui arrive de la
part des services de renseignement aux
russes même s'il ya eu aussi visiblement
des défaillances de la part du fsb qui
sont les services intérieurs héritiers
du kgb de la part du géant et reiki et
le service de renseignement militaire
russes et la part des services
extérieurs les le svr on se souvient
d'ailleurs de la séquence au conseil
national de sécurité le patron du svr
qui est essayé de 2,2 de bredouiller une
petite différence d'approché poutine lui
avait clairement dit bah dit les choses
clairement il avait approuvé du bout des
lèvres l'invasion russe en ukraine donc
il a effectivement sans doute un
problème de fiabilité presque de
compétence des services russes sur le
terrain visiblement il avait sous-estimé
l'état de l'art me craignent haine de la
population ukrainienne et donc tous a
déjà été un peu une défaillance mais il
avait quand même quelques infos qu'ils
ont remonté aux conseillers et la
visuellement ça n'arrive pas à poutine
dont qu'il avait une vision complètement
déformée tout ça côté occidental les
services occidentaux notamment alors
britanniques et américains je le disais
était visiblement mieux informés en
souvient que services américains avaient
dit il y aura une invasion et alors il
ya un ricochet aujourd'hui côté français
cette fois ci c'est que le chef de la
drm la direction du renseignement
militaire éric vidaud a été limogé cette
fois seulement après sa nomination il y
avait déjà eu l'épisode avec les sous
marins australiens on s'en souvient où
visiblement les renseignements français
n'était pas tout à fait au top on va
dire est là et bien on estime que la
nature des services de recueillis par la
france faisait que paris n'anticipait
pas vraiment une invasion russe est
d'ailleurs le chef d'état major de
l'armée thierry bourgard l'avait reconnu
début mars dans une interview un grand
quotidien du soir comme on dit où il
avait du bon lait les anglo saxons en
fait pour eux c'était évident qu'il y
aurait une invasion nous nous étions sur
une approche différente il n'a pas dit
nous nous sommes trompés mais ça voulait
dire ça donc peut-être c'est le résultat
aujourd'hui de cette analyse mais la
question centrale de renseignement merci